let's say
uh I've always had a utility room or
somewhere that I can just eat the keep
my M I usually put it in the
corner and before I go to bed I don't do
it now but I usually before go bed I
just used to open the back door I used
to just go
I'd do three or five and i' I'd put it
back in the
corner I don't know what possessed me to
do that but something told me that I was
using strength all the time in my
natural
life but when I'm going to bed the last
thing I want to do is wake myself up so
I don't want to do powerful hard cutting
I want to do something that lets me go
of bed so
but I wanted to do something so I could
go to bed because they say that sleeping
on something you're absorbing
it so what I get now is even when I'm
doing you know I'm going full
power how quick can I bring that
calmness back
from hey oh that felt good I mean that's
going you're not going to about to go to
bed after three of them because you know
you're going to be
buzzing the same as hopefully most of
you after normal I practice night you go
home and you're more awake than I got to
bed yet what you mean it's only 11 where
normally so so that's natural and I
still get that today I still get it
today
what I'm saying for personal practice if
you've got a back door or you've got a
little space where you can swing that or
you J
but see I had this Theory by doing it
slowly I could get the
foot to land at the same time as
can and at first the foot's there first
then the K or Ken first and then you
bring the foot out so I would spend
these little pieces in the daytime at
night
going and you know you might stagger a
bit
or quickly bring your foot out so you'll
go through all these mental
processes but then event usually you
won't work out your foots you got too
much weight on your front foot you can't
you're
just so if I'm doing what Alex was doing
going backwards I use that power to
bring the Ken
backwards forwards is the is the result
of the going
backward if you go backward
and then go forwards foots first then
the cut you've got Thomas's problem
where you're trying to cor so much that
you're actually throwing it out more
than you
are you can all if the foot gets they're
too quick there a little trick that I
used to do foots they're too quick I
used to keep the heel
up and let the heel go down last so that
would satisfy me that
right I'm coordinating the last part
any and then it becomes enjoyable but
that's talking to you after 49
years um but I also give you the answer
that my student
got a massive amount within four months
so it doesn't take you 50 years it just
you got to work
out so this is the foot again if it gets
too quick keep the heel up push it down
slowly when you're coming forward same
thing push it down
slowly foot hand
cut or comes
together this then means that your body
is
working as one so I've changed the cut
to what I call the helicopter Blade the
feet are
remembered to be there the same as the
forceing once you've done that you can
start
turning and
getting
movement I don't know if that helps but
I enjoyed myself